to our top story tonight Good Samaritans
came across a devastating scene as they
found a dog abandoned in a closed kennel
the dog was found near Green Valley and
sunset as Victoria Saha reports it
appears he was there for days before
being rescued we do want to warn you
some of these images may be disturbing
they call him Saint he just has a
Soulful look in his eyes and he's just
he's just perfect and in our minds
Saints are perfect but those eyes also
represent the neglect and fear this pup
has been through Saint was found last
week abandoned in a kennel by Green
Valley and sunset it was clear he had
been there for a while and needed to get
out there is so much thesis in the
kennel and he was covered in it Saint
was taken to the animal foundation to
get cleaned up and examined it was
determined he was an eight-month-old
German Shepherd weighing just 17 pounds
Tina Hayes with Vegas Pet Rescue project
took Saint under their wing for
intensive care at the hospital and it's
going to take some time and some
nutrients and stuff to get the bones to
realize that they're not stuck in that
crate anymore and let us back straighten
out all four of saints Paws have
chemical burns on them making it nearly
impossible to walk but the good news is
with the right treatment and tender
loving care he should be back on his
paws again Victorious Saha 8 News Now
local businesses are asked to check
their surveillance cameras to see if
they can spot anyone who dumped saint